motivation should follow action not the
other way around
it's
this is huge right that
i can't i don't know where people learn
this notion that they have to feel like
it they have to be in the mood but
that's part of the procrastinator song i
don't want to i don't feel like it'll
feel more like it tomorrow it's as if
we're waiting for our muse
we're waiting for that bus to come
that's going to pick us up and give us
our motivation
well that bus doesn't stop here anymore
and so motivation typically follows
action and it goes back to that notion i
said earlier if we make even a little
bit of progress on a goal it fuels our
well-being and that's when we intersect
with motivation now we can talk more
about motivation if i'm riffing on it
i'd say motivation is at the
intersection of will and skill and
that's where we might bring in mahayana
chicks notion of flow for example when
my
will and my skill match and i'm
challenging myself just a little bit
beyond perhaps what my skill level can
be but i'm working hard and i completely
lose myself and i get into that state
magical state of flow and then and i use
the word already that's when the magic
happens hey friends thank you so much
for watching if you enjoyed this clip
then click here for the full unedited
episode and if you like that then do
please consider subscribing to the
channel it means a lot thank you so much
and have a great day